that you will not allow me to answer a
single question. You know what? You've
made all your points and they all
turn out to be So, let me
bring in Dave. Dave, look, I don't like
to keep saying the word but
when you hear a lot of you
have to call it for what it is.
When I give £10 in charity and it is
consumed, the rewards come to an end.
However, if I give to a ra then you've
put your money into something permanent,
which means a endowment that continues
to give on your behalf until the day you
meet Allah subhana tala. Subhan Allah.
That is amazing. There are iman legacy
brothers and sisters. We want you to
build a legacy with your saddaka. Where
will your donation be going? Events,
global events inspiring the iman of
millions around the world. Education,
free Quran lessons, free lectures, free
reminders. Number three, media content
for kids, educational shows, spiritual
Islamic shows online. Brothers and
sisters, go to the link inshallah and
donate in this blessed 10 days
inshallah. May Allah bless you guys.
Asalam alalaykum.
Asalam alaikum. Welcome to brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Piers Morgan,
our pro Palestinian activist finally is
with Dave Smith. Dave Smith is a Jewish
man. Yes, he's ethnically Jew. I don't
know about if he's religiously Jew and
he is there and Blum says you you will
be absolutely shocked at this story,
this British lawyer that most likely has
kids of her own. Yeah, most likely she
has kids of her own and she is there
defending an absolute genocide. Let's
hear for ourselves. And so much so I
mean Pier ended up using foul foul
language towards her you know and he was
actually amazed he actually said that
she was worse than the ambassador. Let's
talk about our selfish. Let's see what
we have. Well last week nine out of 10
children in one home where two doctors
reside was killed in an air strike. Was
that what wasarkable? What was that?
That has been based only on the basis of
hearsay. You don't believe that story. I
want these stories. Wait wait wait wait
a minute. Look even even Peter is
shocked. He's easing whoa whoa whoa
whoa. What's a good what? You don't
believe that those children were killed?
I have seen conflicting accounts and I
want that story to be properly
investigated before the international
media runs with it. I have You think
those two parents, one of whom I think
operated on on one of the children? I
have a question. Do you think that those
two doctors, the parents, they just made
it up and nine of their 10 children had
been blown to pieces by an Israeli air
strike. If this is true, you don't
believe it. Well, there why on earth was
artificially generated imagery used to
promote this story when it first Hold on
a second. If artificial uh imagery was
used, whoever it was used by, doesn't
matter. How does that make the story not
true? If I was shot somewhere and I had
a bullet wound on my chest and somebody
used an artificial thing, how does that
make it true? Or how does it make it
false that I was not shot? What the hell
are you talking about? This is
despicable. And this is a woman who
probably has children of her own. But
don't forget, guys, she's getting paid
millions of pounds to defend Israel.
That's the reason why she's doing it.
She's, you know why she's doing this?
Because she's thinking about her kids'
future. She's defending a monster. an
evil evil monster, a machine, a massacre
machine, genocidal mania. She's
defending them so she can give a better
future to her kids at the cost of hiding
the massacre and the genocide of other
children of Palestinian children. Just
bear that in mind, guys. She There's no
other reason she's doing this except for
this for her children's wellbeing. Yeah.
At the cost of other people's kids. I
got to say, Natasha, I think what you
just said about that family is is
despicable. I'm sorry. It's despicable.
somebody. You talk about blood liel like
David Dave said. You talk about blood
label. You talk about lies. You talk
about promoting propaganda. And here you
sit here as a lawyer and you say that
you do not believe those nine children
were killed. I didn't say that. You're
putting words in my mouth. I said, "Do
you believe it or not?" said that they
were conflicted and it needs to be
invested. I thought you would be The
parents said nine of their 10 children
were killed. Oh, no. She didn't say
that. You know, it's like saying, "Oh,
will this person a masculine?" I'm like,
"I'm not not sure." I'm not saying they
didn't. I'm just like, I'm not sure.
That's as good as you putting doubt on
the matter. Shame on you. Do you believe
them or did those two doctors make it
up? They haven't said that directly as
far as I have seen. I have seen
secondhand accounts and hearsay. But
it's important to ask why are these
civilians still there? Why is it that
you know it's important to ask whether
you believe that family have lost nine
of their 10 children? I want to know why
the international community you don't.
And this goes to the point that I would
say about Israel. Did she just say why
are civilians still there? Is she
blaming them for being there? Like it's
it's like it's like blaming the rape the
victim. Why was you there? The hell are
you talking about? Now in this war now,
Israel says they don't believe anything.
Everything, every story that comes out
about the deaths of civilians in Gaza,
someone will pop up representing the
Israeli government saying, "Ah, it's
propaganda. It's not true. I've heard
it's not right. I've heard it didn't
happen." And the reason you can get away
with it, frankly, is because you won't
allow the Israeli government won't
allow. I keep I don't want to keep
putting you in the government, but the
is you you defend them. The Israeli
government refuses to allow
international journalists to get in
there and do their job and verify
whether any of these things are actually
happening. And that's exactly true. They
do not allow the journalists and um
everyone can see that for that matter.
The fact that people uh like the two of
you will continue to put out this false
information to perpetuate this conflict
to perpetually
disgusting. What have I said? So two of
you these are two two anti-semmites. One
is a Jew. One is PM Pers Morgan the
biggest pro Israeli advocate who's
turned like he's and the only reason
he's turned is now why because he
realizes what's going on. He's he's
smart. She was saying in that sense
that's the reason why we don't buy Pers
by the way. Yeah. Okay. He says then we
give credit to is Dave Smith not you my
friend. Yeah. Okay. Let's carry on. And
now she's blaming them. You've been
objective now. Objective news. You're
pro hammer if you're objective in the
news. We tell the truth you're pro. It's
false. I didn't think anyone could be
more disingenuous than the UK
ambassador. I got to say Natasha you
you've got right up there. You've
crossed that little bar. indicate one
aspect of what I have said that is
incorrect. We will have this
conversation. But so far you are
throwing out appallingly um misconceived
allegations which are um baseless. Do
you know what is not you couldn't answer
the question who was a former IDF guy
obviously and even he was able to admit
a lot of what Israel is now doing is
wrong and and it just shouldn't be
happening the way that it's happening.
when you blindly don't I mean I think
that I'll be honest with you I don't
think there'll be anyone worse than the
Israeli ambassador to the UK this woman
should really talk about I've got to
give it to peers you know speaking
alhamdulillah mass are blindly
ideologically to one side of this
they're a bunch of genocidal maniacs I
think people like Smodri are genocidal
maniacs and I think anyone on the
pro-Israeli side particularly a lawyer
who can listen to what Smodri said last
week and not understand that he is
actually promoting war crimes out of his
very mouth we haven't discussed smri and
I'm not particularly interested in what
he has to say because it's he's the
finance minister of the Israeli
government. Oh yeah, of course you're
not. Of course you know. Let's forget
what Modric said. Yeah, it's fine. Let's
move on. Trolled by terrorist
organizations, Iranian proxies and Kazba
included is despicable. That is the real
issue here that has driven. The real
issue is terrorist organizations prop.
Let me bring David. Let me bring that
you will not allow me to answer a single
question. You know what? You've made all
your points and they all
turn out to be So let me bring
in Dave. Dave, look, I don't like to
keep saying the word But when
you hear a lot of you have to
call it for what it is, And
the truth is, particularly on the
journalist front there. I mean, it is
bull crap. Pierce, but I'm not going to
say she's like a female version of you,
my friend, at the beginning of this
conflict to taste your medicine, my
friend. So, looking in the mirror,
that's how you was trying to convince
when who trying to convince you. They
had to take a massive death toll. Not
like the Russians. Yes. Two Russians,
two Ukrainians killed. Ah, genocide. The
Palestinians 40 50,000. Now, his
morality comes in and kicks in. You
know, you're looking at yourself, my And
that lawyer is you. That's how you was,
my friend. Yeah. Yes. That's that's what
we had to part with. Yeah. And we bull
crap. Yeah. It was definitely bull crap.
What you were saying. There's a very
simple way that all this fog of war
confusion could be could be resolved and
that is to let the journalists in. And
there's a very simple reason why they're
not. They don't want the journalists to
report to the world what is actually
going on. Otherwise, they'd let them in.
Exactly. Sit here and say, "The reason
you've changed your mind is because
you've fallen for the propaganda. You've
fallen for the lies. The reason why
everyone is so outrageous because
they're falling for these propaganda.
They're fall." The truth is that the
reason why Pierce and so many people
around the world are saying are turning
on what the Israeli government is doing
is because it's just so freaking
horrible because we're seeing images
every day of children human God Almighty
has created us to be merciful to protect
others. The prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him said this lowest form of faith
is to move a harmful object from the
rock so no one else gets harmed. And
this is what is. And this man, this
Jewish man, Babe Smith, he's speaking
out. He's a human being. That's why we
say not every Jewish person, you can't
can't blame every Jewish person. You
have to be out of your mind to do
something so ridiculous like that. We
Muslims get that kind of rhetoric. We
will not allow that. There are amazing
amazing Jewish people around the world
who speak out against these Zionists. Do
not conflate them. Suffering through an
ungodly fate. We all sit there and
think, "My god, if those were our kids
that it it's a pure reaction to
witnessing evil." And you got to sit
here and spin the fact that this is all
propaganda or it's all lies. I mean,
look, I admire you being a lawyer and
and trying to defend your client. I
guess that's what lawyers got to do, no
matter how guilty your client is.
Pierce, if I'm ever charged with murder,
get this lady to to represent me. So,
that that's that's who I want on my
team. But the bottom line is that two
former Israeli prime ministers are not
falling for propaganda at this point.
They can't deny it. I mean, there's not
wrong. If he was charged with murder,
give this woman, she will defend you at
any cost. But if the price is right, if
the price is right, targeting
Palestinian civilians when it has been
seeking from the get-go to evacuate them
to provide humanitarian corridors which
it has defended even though Hamas has
fired onto these civilians as they seek
to flee areas where Hamas has embedded
its terror infrastructure in these
civilian areas in What is she talking
about? There was recent footage that
came out of two young men carrying food
for their family being bombed by the
Israelis. Uh uh drone strike. What is
she talking about? Schools, hospitals
and every second house when I was in
Rafa that we saw. That is the truly How
many houses did you see? That is the
truly How many houses did you see? Well,
many of them were destroyed.
You said every every second house you
saw. You saw 10 houses. No, 10. How many
houses did you see? How many houses did
you see? Come on. Come on. And she's
been brought invited by the Israelis, by
the way. Yeah. How many houses did you
see? What did you see? You know when
they invited Elon Musk and they show
some bullet uh you know um bullets etc
in a baby's little bed. Subhan Allah.
It's not going to work. Plural of the
matter is hang on. How many but how
much? You said every second house. So
how many did you say? No. Every second
house. How many houses did you go into?
It doesn't matter. It does matter.
You've made a statement. You said every
second house. How many did you go into?
We there were the houses were not there.
You know how many houses you went into?
Tens. Well, what? 10, 15, 20? Pier,
you're missing the point here. No, no, I
know the point is you made a claim. I've
simply asked you to give me a number.
Numbers are not your strong point. I
know that begard, but I imagine you
remember how many houses you went into.
No, we saw destroyed houses in the Rafa
area because Hamas has been using these
houses as part of its terror
infrastructure. How do you know? Uh no
actually if you think about it guys the
reason why Hamas um uses those house
already destroyed so because they're
having a war a conflict with um to
combatants yes okay they're having
combatant Hamas is using those houses
that have been destroyed to put booby
traps not the other way around she's
claiming that as how could Hamas access
all these houses of civilians and go hey
listen you know your house that's you
know just the normal house etc we're
going why would they put a booby trap in
a house that is occupied. Yes. Okay. Or
for example, if it's not even occupied.
Okay. Unless the enemy combatants they
need to be enemy combatants. Yes. Enemy
combatants are coming in that building.
So it's not the other way around cuz
they make clear. You said you went into
them and you said again. You're putting
words in my mouth. If you would listen,
I think things would be a lot clearer.
Um Hamas have made you know what was
inside houses even though you didn't go
inside them and they were all
obliterated. Well, you know I couldn't
go inside them because they were booby
trapped behind. didn't go inside them
and they were all destroyed, but you
knew they were all full of Hamas stuff.
What I did see is drone footage that
goes into drone footage that went into
these houses that demonstrated. You
didn't go into the houses. You didn't
see any Hamas stuff in there, but you
saw drone footage
the idea make it very clear. Sorry, it's
just flannel, isn't it? You always take
Hamas's word for it. So, listen to what
they You wouldn't take your word for it.
It sounds like a lot of old
again. Well, listen. Uh, Pierce, as I've
uh dealt with this argument with Douglas
Murray and and now here today. Now,
here, Dave Smith, a Jewish man, is about
to annihilate this shameless lawyer.
He's going to go down in history. She's
going to go down in history. This is
about as serious as Dennis Rodman
claiming that Kim Jong-un showed him a
supermarket full of food. You know, I
mean, I don't know what to say here. And
and it would be equally ridiculous if I
went on some Hamas sponsored tour and
then came back telling you that
everything they say is correct. Here's
the bottom line. I have a much more
clear, logical answer. The reason why
two former Israeli prime ministers,
including Omar, who is a right-winger,
who was Chiron's guy, this is not as if
this is some left-wing anti-war peace or
something like that. The reason why two
former Israeli prime ministers have come
out and said that Israel is committing
war crimes in Gaza is because Israel is
committing war crimes in Gaza. The
reason why Israel will not let
journalists into Gaza is because Israel
is committing war crimes in Gaza. And
the reason why Israel is killing uh
Palestinian civilians in Gaza and the
reason why they're building up more
settlements in the West Bank is because
as Smootri has said, as Katz uh the
defense minister has said this week and
as Benjamin Netanyahu has said for years
and years and years, their plan is
greater Israel. They want Gaza and the
West Bank. They call it Judea and
Samaria. They believe that it's
rightfully Israel's. Benjamin Netanyahu
showed up to the United Nations a couple
weeks before October 7th with a map
where it was all Israel. That's the
bottom line. Exactly. That's exactly. He
came with a map, you know, and that is
their plan. Slowly but gradually. Slowly
but gradually. That's their plan. It's
why they've been controlling these
territories since 1967. See, the truth
makes a lot more sense. And by the way,
you know that Israel has nuclear
weapons, but you won't say it on this
program because you're not in the
business of telling the truth about this
conflict. You're in the business of
defending Israel, which is fine. That's
what you want to do. But all three of us
know they have nuclear weapons. Maybe we
should get into the where does
international law stand on the US and
the UK being partners with a country
who's not in the non-prololiferation
treaty who has nuclear weapons. Maybe we
could have a whole conversation on that
next time. Pierce, I mean, you can see
it clearly from her face. You can
clearly see it from her face. She's only
It's like, you know, she's only doing
that because of of of the money. That's
That's what it is, guys. No one in their
right mind would ever defend Israel. No
way in hell. You can see it. It's like
in the back of her head, she's like, you
know, just making herself her conscious,
feel better, and doing for this, for the
money, for the kids, for my kids'
future, etc. I have no choice. But I
promise you, this woman is a human
being. It's impossible. She she's a
mother. She's most likely a mother going
to be a mother. It's impossible that a
woman like that who sees babies children
and denies that except there is a utter
motive and sisters.
May Allah subhana expose them.
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah. Wallah
Allah is exposing with their own hands.
They're losing this war, this battle on
all grounds. The whole entire world has
woken up to how evil these Zionists are.
They are evil and they are behind all
kinds of stuff. And I believe this call
conspiracy. I promise you those attacks
that have been done around the world,
I'm not going to go details. They are
behind it. They are behind it. They are
behind it. I promise you. And on their
judgment, we are going to see. Brothers
and sisters, till next time.
Inshallah. Do not forget mom sisters to
support the